Paris a bustling metropolis it's home to
2.2 million people it's streets and
public spaces serve as a canvas for many
artists who choose to express themselves
in the form of street art murals and
collages can be found on buildings
across the city Charlevoix or Laval a as
he's known belongs to this group of
artists he's trained in visual arts and
taught in French schools yet his
preferred platform is Paris's open
spaces he calls this collage human
resources he can imagine a reservoir of
employees who are standing by in a
cupboard and come out one by one when
they're needed you could see this as a
critique of the business world or even a
tea cup several other things but really
there is no specific message here
[Music]
lavalla is fast becoming one of the most
famous street artists in Paris he uses
walls and their architectural nuances as
a canvas these pieces are sometimes
poetic sometimes critical but he leaves
the general interpretation up to the
viewer
[Music]
each person can take away whatever they
want it's their interpretation as I've
said there is no strict or clear message
yep I do misogynistic declare three
years ago Laval a caught the eye of one
Parisian gallery owner who was looking
to do a project with several street
artists in the district of momot the
result was an entire Avenue where the
building's walls were decorated with
various scenes now he creates
exhibitions for galleries not an easy
move for a street artist it's difficult
for a street artist to make the
transition to a gallery because of the
context you have either art for the
street or for the gallery and these are
two totally different things so you
can't really transfer it that's what you
have to keep in mind Laval a has
recently created works which are now on
display in Berlin - were pasted on a
residential street in the trendy mitad
district and like the ones in Paris they
add some humor to a drab building wall
gallery owners meanwhile are betting on
his future success
the thing that's different about Charles
that he works according to a plan that
means that each work is thought out and
created for a specific location on the
street to exhibit in a gallery it's
necessary to find a format that
corresponds contrary to his works on the
street which carry no particular meaning
his exhibition at the open walls gallery
in Berlin is very specific about the
physical and mental barriers in our
daily lives little boxes is an
exhibition dealing with the subject of
the box as an object and also as a
symbol what interested me was to work on
the subject of containment the box is an
allegory for all of the boxes that we
pass through in our existence Charlevoix
expresses his ideas and a humorous yet
intense fashion and even as he gains in
popularity on the art scene he says he's
determined to stay true to the streets
of Paris
you